this video is brought to you by athletic
greens and his wonderful daily blend of
vitamins and minerals ag1 by athletic
greens is comprehensive all-in-one
greens powder engineered to fill the
nutritional gaps in your diet and
support your body's nutritional needs
across four pillars of Health gut health
immune sport energy and Recovery is
packed with 75 vitamins and minerals and
Whole Food sourced ingredients combining
the perfect amount of micronutrients
absorption and taste to jump start your
daily routine you'll be hard-pressed to
find a more comprehensive powder or
supplement on the market right now now
look as you guys know I'm not exactly a
fitness YouTuber but I still do like to
eat right and take care of myself and
ag1 is that comprehensive nutrition
supplement that I know is going to
account for any holes that I might have
in my diet you just take one scoop from
this and you put it in this bottle
Shaker every day with the powder and
easy shake it up I have it in the
morning typically with my coffee and it
also tastes great plus it's gluten-free
dairy-free paleo vegan keto low allergen
and low calorie less than one gram of
sugar in that well things I like about
it I feel it gives me more sustained
energy like I drink that coffee I have
my aesthetic greens and I feel set up
for the day it's the perfect dietary
support regiment so this sounds like the
supplement you've been looking for then
you can grab your own immunity bundle
which also contains a year's supply of
vitamin D and five of the super handy
travel pouches so you could have your
ag1 while on the go these come free with
your first purchase so all you need to
do is go to athleticgreens.com
biographics again year Supply vitamin D
the five travel pouches at
athleticreens.com biographics or just
click the link in the description below
and now today's video
foreign
six the United States was gearing up to
celebrate the 100th anniversary of its
founding the country needed to celebrate
an economic depression had gripped the
nation for the last three years there
was controversy and Scandal surrounding
the administration of President Ulysses
S Grant and hanging over everyone oily
unhealed scars of the recently concluded
Civil War then from the West word came
up a military disaster in Far Away
Montana territory in a place called The
Little Bighorn of a 250 Troopers of the
Army's 7th Camry regiment have been
killed in a fight with hostile Indians
most shocking of all though was the fact
that the regiment's famed Commander
Colonel George Armstrong Custer was
among the dead at the time Custer was
one of the most famous men in America
he'd been a northern hero during the
Civil War famous for his dramatic
Cavalry Charges and responsible for some
of the Union's biggest victories after
the war he became the country's most
famous Indian fighter due just as much
to his own propensity for self-promotion
as for his military skill he'd also been
involved in a number of Scandal that
would have destroyed his military career
had even anybody else but he always
managed to find a way out a remarkable
streak of Good Fortune the
contemporaries know as Custer's luck now
that luck had run out but it seemed in
death Custer was even more famous than
he was alive the dramatic Last Stand
made by him and his cavalrymen was
almost immediately compared to the story
of the 300 Spartans thermopoly with
Custer taking on the role of the spot
and King Leonidas for decades Custer was
held up as American martyr to the
winning of the West a hero without
Pierre a more recent analysis has been
more critical however not only of his
active participation in the shameful
actions taken by the American government
against the Indian tribes of the Great
Plains but also for his Reckless
impulsive decisions many of which got
people killed
foreign
George Armstrong Custer was born on
December 5th 1839 in New Rumley Ohio a
tiny and remote farming Community
located 100 miles south of the city of
Cleveland the customers were a large
hard-working family with a lot of love
to go around George nicknamed aorti
because he kept mispronouncing his
middle name when he was a toddler I was
an outgoing boy who I like to read and
was a decent student compared to his
peers at the age of 16 he graduated from
primary school and briefly became a
school teacher until he achieved what he
declared to be his life's ambition an
appointment to the United States
Military Academy at West Point New York
the trading ground for the nation's army
officers Cadet Custer's record at West
Point from 1857 to 1861 is legendary for
all the wrong reasons one of the most
popular students in his class it seemed
wherever there was a Mischief going on
Custer could be found right in the
middle of it he enjoyed pushing
boundaries and testing the limits of
authority he was always in trouble for
something racking up 726 demerits during
his first four years at the academy one
of the worst disciplinary records in the
history the school academically was a
firm believer in the philosophy Seas get
degrees he'd do the bare minimum to pass
the classes never studying if he could
avoid it he'd prefer to do things that
interested him instead sometimes these
interests got him into trouble too he
was treated for gonorrhea in his junior
year probably contracted from a New York
prostitute with all these Shenanigans
during his time at West Point it seems a
near miracle that he managed to graduate
at all but he did dead last under normal
circumstances this would not have boded
well for his future prospects in the
Army and it is likely nobody would have
ever heard of George Armstrong Custer
but these were not normal circumstances
when Custer graduated in June 1861 the
Civil War was already two months old and
the Union Army needed all the qualified
officers it could get
Custer was spat out by the academy
almost directly onto Battlefield less
than a month after graduating customers
on hand witnessed the union disaster at
the First Battle of Bull Run the first
major battle of the war and a stinging
defeat for the North Custer would next
the action in March 1862 now a Cavalry
officer in the newly reorganized Army of
the Potomac under the command of Major
General George McClellan mcclellan's
Peninsula Campaign that spring failed
due to his own timidity and the
emergence of Confederate General Robert
E Lee to leadership of the Rebel Army of
Northern Virginia but Custer fought well
catching the attention of McClellan who
promoted him to Aid to comp when
McClellan was fired by President Abraham
Lincoln that November Caster found
himself out of a job for a few months
his next assignment was as a to General
Alfred Pleasanton the commander of the
army of the potomacs Cavalry Corps at
the end of June 1863 pleasantonson
received permission to remove so-called
political generals politicians playing
at War who weren't actually good at it
with Prof professionals willing to risk
their lives leading their units one of
the officers he believed fit that bill
was Captain Custer only two years after
graduating from the academy at the
tender age of 23 Custer was promoted to
Brigadier General a truly meteoric rise
for a man that his troops would call the
boy General Guster was given command to
the Michigan Cavalry Brigade known as
the Wolverines the first assignment was
crucial Robert E Lee's army had invaded
the northern states marching through
Maryland and into Pennsylvania hoping to
trap the Union Army and destroy it the
army of the Potomac now commanded by
George Mead followed making sure that
they stayed between Lee and the federal
capital Washington DC the two armies
would crash into each other on the 1st
of July 1863 at Gettysburg in
Pennsylvania on the morning of July 3
1863 General Custer's Brigade was posted
three miles east of the Union infantry
lines they had seen sporadic fighting
over the last two days as the Infantry
slugged away at each other in the
bloodiest battle of the entire War both
generals were warned that a large body
of Rebel Cavalry was in the area and
they prepared to fight however Cavalry
commanded by the famous General Jeb
Stewart emerged from the trees six
thousand strong more than twice the
number of Union troops Stewart's mission
was to support the Infantry assault on
the union position led by General George
Pickett to do that he needed to break
through the Union Cavalry after three
hours of fighting Caster's men still
held and Stewart knew if he was going to
accomplish his mission he needed to
attack now with everything he had
thousands of mounted Horsemen Road at
the Yankees in a wave of Cavalry that
would have scared most commanders but
not George Custer despite being
dramatically outnumbered Custer wouldn't
yield the field without a fight the
young General rode to the head of his
men drew his saber knocked his hat off
his head so everyone could recognize his
distinctive long flowing blonde hair and
shouted cabanu Wolverines and then he
charged straight at the Rebels the
leading ranks of both sides crashed into
each other with tremendous Force sending
horses toppling to the ground end over
end crushing their Riders all
organizational cohesion was lost the
battle collapsed into a confused melee
individual Troopers slashing at each
other with their Sabers or firing on
each other with pistols at Point Blank
Range More Union Cavalry struck the
Confederates in their flanks in support
of Caster's attack and the rebel attack
fizzled out soon enough Stuart received
the news that Pickett's Charge had
failed it was repulsed with heavy losses
and he ordered his Troopers back the
fight at the East Cavalry field as it
would become known was over overnight
General Custer was a household name a
hero lauded by both his supporters and
the northern newspapers there was
perhaps his finest hour
customer did the Michigan Cavalry
Brigade with great distinction for the
rest of the war participating in several
more major engagements in April 1865 he
was the first Union general to receive a
flank of truce from the rebels as their
position became hopeless he was present
at Appomattox when General Lee formally
surrendered his army effectively ending
the war in recognition for his service
to the Union victory Custer's Commander
General Philip Sheridan purchased the
table the two generals had used to sign
the articles of surrender and presented
it to Custer's new wife Elizabeth known
as Libby Custer ended the war as a major
general and a hero to the Victorious
North he was only 25 years old obviously
great things were in his future though
alsoever one-leaming problem with the
war over the Grand Army of the Republic
was being broken up its soldiers sent
home to resume their civilian lives the
peacetime Army was to be much much
smaller than the two million men must
during the war and for those
professional officers that wish to
remain in the Army well the fact was
there were simply more generals than
there were slots to employ them so
George Custer who once commanded
thousands found himself a lieutenant
colonel in command of a single Cavalry
Regiment the seventh United States
Cavalry Garrison Duty in Western forts
was a far cry from glorious Cavalry
chaunders on Civil War battlefields his
soldiers were not the idealistic
volunteers he commanded before but poor
immigrants who were often the only ones
willing to accept the low pay and dismal
conditions that the Army offered and
they all increasingly grew to dislike
Custer the man was not transitioning
well to his loss of rank and
responsibility and started taking it out
on his subordinates with random
outbursts of temper and often blurring
the lines between strict discipline and
outright cruelty his erratic Behavior
ended in 1867 when he was core martial
for being absent without leave from his
post and conduct on becoming an officer
it was suspended without pay for a year
which seems harsh until you consider
that if it had been any other officer he
would have been dismissed from the Army
entirely his War record and his powerful
friends in the high command allowed him
to get away with a slap on the wrist
it's not the last time this occurs in
his career
[Music]
in 1868 the American Indian tribes on
the Great Plains were growing
increasingly tired of the US
government's failed Promises to Keep
white settlers out of territory promised
to them by treaties tribes like the
Lakota and the Cheyenne began raiding
white settlements fighting back against
what they saw as encroachments on their
land and their way of life unfortunately
this gave the government pretext for war
against the Hostile Savages as most
whites of the time period believed them
to be that winter George Sheraton
planned an operation designed to force
the southern shared bans onto designated
reservations which would open up other
land for White Settlement the fact that
these lands were far away from the
Buffalo herds that the plains tribes
relied on was not a consent one of the
Cheyenne bands that was not yet on the
reservation was a group of about 200 led
by Chief Black Kettle survivor of the
massacre of over 150 peaceful Shan and
Arapaho Sand Creek four years earlier
despite his negative past with white
black cattle was widely known as a peace
Chief who did not want war but some of
his younger Warriors known as dog
soldiers would not be restrained and
went out on raids the seventh Cavalry
found the tracks of one of these raiding
parties and followed them back to Black
cattle's Winter encampment along the
banks of the Washita River in modern day
Western Oklahoma on November 27 1868
Custer attacked the camp in accordance
with Sheridan strategy to destroy the
Shands livestock and shelters and force
them to surrender and move to the
reservation a total war strategy that
had been greatly successful in the South
during the Civil War the action of
Washita which has been called both the
battle and Massacre sparked controversy
both in 1868 and today the reported
number of Cheyenne dead ranges from 20
to over 100 Liberty will ever know for
sure the date included Black Kettle shot
in the back while trying to flee from
the village with his wife at least some
of those killed were women and children
and one of the controversies over the
action is whether they were caught in
the crossfire or whether they were
deliberately targeted by the Troopers
particularly controversial was the
decision by Custer to take over 50 women
and children prisoner to use as human
Shields preventing the Warriors from
firing on the Cavalry as they departed
for fear of hitting their own family
members various atrocities were reported
against these captives supposedly in
retribution for similar outrages
committed on white settlements whatever
the opinion about the action itself
Custer's reputation remained intact
there was a la the military operations
after Washita as the regiment was
transferred first to Kentucky and then
to the Dakota territory Custer tried his
hand at a number of business ventures
during this downtime all of which were
failures except for writing about his
exploits in newspapers and he eventually
published a book called my life on the
planes despite growing complaints from
his subordinates he still had the trust
of his superiors continuing to receive
important assignments like leading an
expedition into the black hills region
of South Dakota in 1870 for this
Expedition though Custer had no idea at
the time proved to be the start of the
final drama in his colorful life the
Black Hills were explicitly included in
the Fort Laramie Treaty of 1868 as part
of the reservation of the Lakota or
Sioux people thus technically Custer's
expedition was a violation of the treaty
though officials didn't think it would
pose a significant issue because the
troops didn't intend to stay everything
changed however when Custer reported
that his expedition had found gold Bell
and once leaked to the newspapers it set
off a wave of excitement a gold rush
soon took shape with Prospectors
flooding into the area in the hopes of
striking Rich the Army tried to keep
them out but conflict with the Lakota
soon broke out with the country in a
depression since 1873 President Ulysses
S Grant knew that an influx of gold
would be a much needed boost to the
economy his officials made an attempt to
purchase the Black Hills from the Lakota
but they refused to sell the Black Hills
were sacred to them the place they
believed the spirits at first created
the world it was the center of their
entire universe instance how could you
put a monetary value on that
the Americans decided they were just
going to take the Black Hills instead
but once again they needed a pretext for
a war with the Lakota they found it in
the lands west of the great Zoo
reservation in Montana and Wyoming where
many of the Lakota and Cheyenne still
followed after the Buffalo like their
Generations irrespective of arbitrary
lines on a map the government in the
Army decided to force these bans onto
the reservation knowing that they would
resist and that it would lead to open
War the government sent word to the
Indians in the unseeded land that they
were required to move by January 31 1876
or be considered hostile the deadline
was a shame and everyone knew it even if
the bands in question have been inclined
to move they would have been unable to
until spring Thor when the deadline
passed General Sheridan enacted his
warplan troop Collins moved into the
area from the west east and south hoping
to trap ball star bands and a pincer
Custer in the seventh Cavalry were part
of the Dakota column which left Fort
Abraham Lincoln in North Dakota and
headed Western to Montana in May 1876.
all three columns were to converge in
the area of the Bighorn Little Bighorn
rivers in southern Montana where it was
believed that the largest concentration
of Indian incumbents were they were more
right than they realized on the banks of
Little Bighorn was the largest Plains
Indian camp in living memory every
Warrior who wanted to fight the whites
had gathered in one place drawn by the
leadership of the coast
believed to be a powerful medicine man
whose Visions foretold a great Indian
victory over the whites the warriors
were a mix of Lakota Northern Shan and
Arapaho numbering between 1500 and 2000
Warriors twice as many as pre-war
government estimates Custer and the
seventh Cavalry detached from the rest
of the column to a scout ahead and they
found this Village early on the morning
of June the 25th despite being warned by
his Crow and arakara Scouts about the
size of the village Custer still
believed that he was facing no more than
800 including non-combatants like women
and children he decided not to wait for
reinforcements because he believed had
been spotted and was worried various
bands would scatter he believed the
Indians would run away when he attacked
another flawed assumption Guster split
his regiment numbering about 700 men
into battalions for the attack he
himself LED five companies to ride
around the village and attack from the
north while three companies under the
command of major Marcus Reno attacked
from the south renoating found himself
heavily engaged by far more Warriors
than he'd been inspecting and was
compelled to retreat to a Hilton top
where he was joined by three companies
led by Captain Frederick benteen who had
been similarly overwhelmed while trying
to support Custer this group found
itself surrounded fighting for its life
over the course of the next two days
before the approach of the rest of the
Dakota column compelled Sitting Bull to
disband the encampment and the various
bands headed off in different directions
it was only then on June the 27th that
his comrades found out what had happened
into Custer's group to the northeast of
where the encampment had been was a
grizzly scene blue coated bodies were
lying all over many of them scalped or
mutilated on a Hilltop known today as
Last Stand Hill George Armstrong
Custer's body was found surrounded by
the bodies of his men he'd been shot
twice in the head and in the heart every
man he led into battle that day met the
same fate over 200 in all the dead
included two of Custer's Brothers his
brother-in-law and his nephew at only 36
years old his once brilliant military
career had entered in disaster
foreign
the news of the defeat and the death of
Custer in the Battle of Little Bighorn
reached the East Coast during the
nation's Centennial celebrations and was
met with shock and Horror by the
American public Libby Custer emerged
from her morning period determined to
preserve her late husband's reputation
she believed it died a hero and deserved
to be recognized as such she blamed
major Reno and Captain Ben Dean for the
death of her husband accusing them of
cowardice a court of inquiry held in
1879 found Reno blameless for the defeat
but accusations that he was incompetent
or a coward or a drunk dogged him until
his death and many years afterwards
initially Custer was buried with his men
on the battlefield but in 1877 his body
was exhumed at least it was believed to
be his body some historians believed
they might have actually dug up the
wrong corpse and it was brought to West
point where he was reinterred with full
military honors in the West Point
Cemetery by that point the great Sioux
war was over the victory at the Little
Bighorn only delaying the inevitable
Lakota Chief Crazy Horse who had led his
Warriors to victory was compelled to
surrender in 1877 and was building
custody a few months later Sitting Bull
went with his band to Canada and
banished to hold out until 1881 when he
too was forced to come in the US
government forced the Lakota to give up
the Black Hills by threatening to Cut
Off Their Food Supplies on the
reservation if they did not comply
facing starvation they had no choice
over a hundred years later in 1980 the
Supreme Court ruled that the Black Hills
had been illegally taken from the
lakotas they ordered the United States
compensate the Sioux Nation for its loss
money that the Lakota have refused to
take because they never wanted to sell
the land in the first place Libby Custer
was her husband's biggest advocate in
the decades after Little Bighorn and
it's largely responsible for his initial
status as the American martyr and the
cultural memory of the country Custer
was one of the heroes of the old west
and essential character in any game of
cowboys and Indians and the story of His
Last Stand became one of the most famous
in American history his character has
appeared in at least 30 movies including
by such famous actors as Errol Flynn and
Ronald Reagan and many books were
written about him often hagiographic in
nature however as the the United States
began to come to grips with the awful
tragedy that had been inflicted on
American Indians in the 18th and 19th
centuries not only on the Great Plains
but all over the country people began to
view George Custer's life and deeds in a
new light because he had been so famous
almost mythical he was singled out for
special criticism military researchers
have concluded that the defeat at Little
Bighorn was largely cussed his own fault
that had blundered into a situation he
didn't fully understand and had gotten
himself and his men killed whether he
did so out of a misguided sense of Duty
or out of a vainglorious need to Heap
further Laurels upon himself or a
mixture of both his upper debate Today
George Custer provides a much more mixed
reaction than he did 100 years ago some
have called him a butcher a callous
murderer accused of killing and raping
women and children using them as human
Shields others claim he was no better or
worse than any other white men of the
period that he didn't hate Indians he
just did what his government ordered him
to do as an army officer a few people
still consider him to be a hero work and
as the years pass and he disappears into
the pages of history that seems unlikely
too many people never will again
[Music]